GUNTHER ROLAND: So over
the last few, last couple
of years, Sean Robinson and
I have made a few changes
to the 8.14 curriculum to
really are differentiate it more
from 8.13 But I mean, a change
that happened a number of years
ago, five years ago, was
sort of the introduction
of this exploratory project.
But then in the last few
years, what we decided to do
was add yet another
communication component,
namely, the poster session.
As the students move
on to graduate school,
posters are one of the
communication forms
they will have to use at
conferences, et cetera.
And I think, like for the
papers and the presentations
in 8.13, the
poster, I mean, when
you have to start for the
first time with a blank slate,
I think it is very different
to find the appropriate form.
So we thought it would be very
good to practice that in 8.14.
And the reason we made this
change is that 8.14 competes
for the students' time with
many other things they can do,
including taking UROPs,
which they feel, correctly,
are important for
their future career.
And we felt that we need
to revamp 8.14 a little bit
to really make it worth
the students' time,
to give them something
on which they
can build for their
graduate school
applications and their
work as graduate students.
And I think many of the--
essentially, all of the students
that take 8.14 in the end,
move on to graduate
school in physics.
And the new components, I
think, really help them,
in both rounding out
their application
and in developing some tools
that they will use later
on as graduate students.